[Musique]
elle aurait écumé des clubs de stand-up
et puis un jour il y a 4 ans elle a
inondé nos téléphones de millions de
paillettes à tous ceux qui parient sur
un buzz elle a répondu par des scènes et
des salles de plus en plus grandes son
prochain terrain de jeu l'accord Arena
alors vital enfin sa meilleure vie Inès
reg est un aparté
en vrai grande timide dans la vraie vie
vous avez vu on a allumé toutes les
lumières on a mis toutes les ampoules au
max se fait que parce que je sais que
vous aimez modérément le noir enfin
surtout la nuit remarqué
une petite lumière où c'est uniquement
quand il est pas là non c'est même quand
il est là et c'est très marrant parce
que d'ailleurs on dort maintenant avec
une une veilleuse qui fait des étoiles
de couleurs
est-ce que vous voulez faire quelque
part pour découvrir cet espace qui vous
est dédié évidemment aujourd'hui
on va faire merci on va faire Bercy je
crois que c'est à qui elle vous mettrez
bien ces chaussures là pour Bercy
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
me fait grandir franchement ça
oui mais vous aimez pas je sens que vous
aimez pas remarqué c'est hyper confort
c'est hyper confort et je trouve que ça
me donne quand même un peu une petite
stature ce que je grandis je fais un
mètre 50 et là je prends au moins aller
5 cm c'est pas négligeable alors écoutez
vous si vous voulez bien emprunter les
escaliers du pied droit du pré-gauche
comme vous voulez
est-ce que vous avez vu le le canapé
vous avez vu il y a une sorte de
contrebas donc on peut pas faire de
miettes
vous pourrez pas planquer les miettes
sous le canapé voilà je préfère vous
dire Inès c'est Madame ça depuis
toujours
il faut quand même que vous m'expliquiez
le truc donc vous vous vous aimez les
biscuits j'aime énormément les biscuits
mais du coup ça en met partout ah oui et
en fait c'est chiant à ramasser parce
que des fois il y a des petits bouts qui
tombent et après on se baisse et tout
alors du coup moi je mets tout par terre
et après je fais comme ça avec le pied
et ça ne fait plus qu'un avec le enfin
je vois tellement de trucs je suis allé
voir vous pouvez même toucher si vous
voulez Inès
ok
on se lance déjà il y a tout mais il y a
toute ma vie alors Oni qui est le film
mais non mais vous êtes trop fort il y a
tout totalise pas et j'ai grandi avec
les Totally Spies et j'attends toujours
que Jerry m'appelle vous connaissez
Totally Spies ou pas un dessin animé
j'ai une petite de 10 ans donc autant
vous dire que j'en mange aussi en fait
ce qui est trop dingue c'est que donc
c'est des espions hyper stylées et en
fait elles sont comme ça elles marchent
et d'un coup il y a ça veut dire que je
pourrais être là en aparté et tout d'un
coup bah Jerry il m'appelle parce que
j'ai une mission et je rentre par la
chemin retrouver de Jerry oui Jerry
c'est un peu comme c'est l'équivalent de
comment il s'appelle dans les trois
drôles de dames ça va me revenir salut
nanani on a oublié le nom
évidemment de Charlie
des enfants et je vois j'ai chanté une
musique les gars j'ai chanté
et oui Inès vous êtes assez complète
assez protéiforme je dois dire j'aime
beaucoup oui et vous allez vite parce
que vous êtes tout jeune à peine 31 ans
ouais j'ai 30 ans même encore
il y a cette vue parce que appartement
avec vue tant qu'à faire c'est plus
confort cette vue sur Paris cette vue
sur Paris avec une petite tension qui
monte parce que évidemment il y a ce
rendez-vous à l'accord Arena
incessamment faut dire que vous êtes
bien échauffé la tournée elle est
phénoménale la tournée de votre premier
spectacle hors norme déjà 390 dates avec
45 Zénith 8 Olympia 30 Casino de Paris
et cette date du 17 juin un humoriste
sur la scène de l'accord Arena vous
savez que ça se compte sur les doigts de
la main mais oui attendez je sais pas si
vous voyez là vous voyez mes frissons
tous mes poils grisés tellement c'est
trop dense vous êtes en train de dire
oui ça se compte sur les doigts de la
main et je n'aurais pu jamais
imaginé faire partie de ses doigts de la
main vraiment pas et alors vous êtes
bien dans cette main et vous vous
échauffez alors c'est rigolo la manière
dont vous échauffez avec Kevin pour ce
grand jour vous voulez bien qu'on
regarde on rentre dans notre intimité
je viens de voir qu'il y avait un
diagnostic
c'est fou ce que je viens de vivre j'ai
rêvé pour ma dernière date de tournée
jouer à Bercy non parce que les gens ont
dit pas merci on dit encore à Rennes
j'ai joué et c'était la folie tu
m'entends et c'est parti
est-ce que vous êtes
chauds
pourquoi tu gâches les qu'est-ce que tu
fais relève toi bien là je te dis qu'on
parle de piercing mon gars on parle d'un
vrai délire écoute bien les gens
essaient torse nu sur ma vie les gens
ils étaient torse nu c'était incroyable
ce genre j'ai l'impression que je me
prémonition on va plus dormir
j'ai tout vu les gens ils hurlèrent on
en va encore et moi je disais quoi je
vais vous en donner plus vous en donner
de taré vous êtes pas vrai
[Musique]
génial on a adoré dans votre intimité on
a adoré évidemment on n'est pas dans le
Nord il y a toujours cette petite
lumière qui vient me rassurer
se rassurer tiens c'est le sujet quand
même parce que vous êtes une timide vous
l'avez dit vous êtes une traqueuse Chine
traqueuse effectivement donc cette date
du 17 juin mais mon dieu vous savez que
j'en fais enfin je ne pense qu'à ça je
vis vers si je me lève vers si je
dors-bien je dors pas d'ailleurs je dors
vraiment pas je pense qu'à ça et j'ai
toutes mes idées arrivent très tard dans
la nuit en fait je me couche vraiment
très tard je me couchage à 5-6 heures je
me couche le matin en fait et du coup
mon cerveau fait que réfléchir et j'ai
tout en 47000 idées et en fait je veux
tout donner et après je me dis non mais
Inès métro qui me fait ça mais sa maison
et puis je m'imagine en fait je
j'essaie de faculté à donc me dire ok je
ferai comme si comme ça et puis je ferme
les yeux et je me vois à vert si je vois
les gens et j'ai l'impression de dire ok
donc là voilà dans mon esprit rigole
donc ça va que ça fonctionné ah ça j'ai
l'impression qu'ils aiment pas et je
travaille vraiment dans ma tête ça veut
dire que Bercy on peut s'attendre à tout
il y aura des surprises
des petites têtes qui seront peut-être
avec moi merci par là-bas je ne sais pas
attendez je vois pas j'aimerais bien non
vraiment vous pouvez pas vous dire juste
une seule chose c'est que
je veux que merci ce soit la ce sera ma
dernière date de spectacle ça fait
quatre ans que je que je joue ce
spectacle et ça fait surtout quatre ans
que on me connaît maintenant depuis
cette vidéo des paillettes et depuis
même le Marrakech du rire tout a
commencé donc je veux vraiment que Bercy
soit les résumés de ce
10 juillet à la télé jusqu'à ce jour de
Bercy donc toutes les belles rencontres
que j'ai pu faire tous les gens qui ont
qui ont fait de moi la femme que je suis
aujourd'hui seront à Bercy et oui ce
sera l'apothéose bien sûr et ça a
commencé comment vous l'avez dit les
paillettes on les a tous regardés en
boucle sur nos téléphones sur nos
ordinateurs regardons mon cœur on sort
ce soir
aller manger dehors
la veste que j'ai sur moi Zara 35 euros
le débardeur
la tablette pour mettre des paillettes
sur mes yeux 65 euros et tu me proposes
un McDo à 10 balles les calculs sont pas
pompiers
[Musique]
c'est quand est-ce qu'on habite Kevin je
veux des moulures au plafond Kevin on
habite dans le 9 3 c'est ça que tu
m'offres
je devrais vivre ma meilleure vie j'ai
27 ans Kevin j'ai 27 ans Kévin j'ai 27
ans Kévin je vais aller bizarre
on s'en laisse pas on s'en lasse pas
vous non plus
contente que ce qui m'a fait connaître
généralement on a des fois un peu honte
on veut oublier ou se donner une
nouvelle image ou montrer autre chose ou
punaise comme je suis trop fière de me
dire on peut me la mettre 5 millions de
fois cette vidéo bah déjà ça me fera
toujours rire et ce rythme mais j'avoue
les gars ça me fait rire et surtout bah
je suis tellement contente je dis
punaise ça va un sens dès le début je
voulais des paillettes dans ma vie et
bah genre je les ai eus c'est ça c'est
mon public c'est c'est ça le remplit
c'est ses lumières tous les soirs c'est
c'est dingue ça s'est passé 20 millions
de vues alors il y avait évidemment les
grincheux qui parlaient d'un buzz à ce
moment là Inès vous vous souvenez bien
sûr j'en suis un très très bien
effectivement on s'attendait à un buzz
un effet de paille après on est dans une
aujourd'hui avec la on vit avec les
réseaux sociaux et oui il y en a plein
en fait des moments comme ça là où il y
a une vidéo qui sort et tout d'un coup
pendant trois semaines on entend parler
de cette personne et puis après plus
jamais sauf que sauf que ce que les gens
ne savaient pas c'est que déjà moi je
viens d'ici et que avant le Marrakech du
rire ça fait 7 ans que je suis sur
toutes les semaines parisiennes et que
ok je suis sur les réseaux sociaux mais
parce que j'ai bien compris que
maintenant c'était ça c'était les
réseaux sociaux tout passait par là mais
de base moi je suis une nana de la scène
7 ans 7 ans c'est long même si vous êtes
très jeune c'est aussi du doute de la
remise en question quand parfois il a
fallu jouer devant quatre personnes je
vous cite exactement ouais ouais j'ai
vraiment j'ai vraiment joué devant
quatre personnes et ouais c'est long
c'est dur il y a des hauts il y a des
bas on n'y croit plus et à ce moment là
que j'ai la chance d'avoir ma famille ma
maman ma sœur autour de moi et qui je
prends un chemin tellement inattendu
qu'on ne connaît enfin nous enfin je
viens du 91 je suis dans ma petite
banlieue etc et puis ça c'est ce qu'on
voit à la télé c'est pour les autres et
c'est pas pour nous en fait et comment
on fait de façon et comment ils sont
arrivés là et enfin on connaît pas ça et
du coup quand je dis moi je suis une
famille où tout le monde a fait des
études ma sœur elle a un bac + 5 elle a
un travail de dingue etc et tout d'un
coup je dis ben moi je veux pas je vais
pas faire des tudes alors que c'est
comme ça qu'on a appris on nous a nos
parents nous ont toujours dit l'école
avant tout c'est très important et là du
coup bah les gars moi je vais je vais
faire du théâtre je vais faire du
stand-up mais Inès il y a 40000 à 40000
personnes qui en font à deux qui sont
connus non mais on va y arriver et quand
je suis tombé parce que je suis tombé
quand j'ai dit j'arriverai pas en fait
ça sert à rien je suis en train de me
battre et j'ai 25 ans et et en fait je
suis rien c'est ce que je veux dire à ce
moment là je suis rien dans le sens les
gars j'ai pas de travail on me connaît
pas j'ai pas de salaire je suis personne
en fait pour le réseau non plus aucun
réseau et je suis très je suis très nul
en
ça va ouais je suis éclaté mais vraiment
alors avant de s'installer à l'accord
Arena Inès on vous installe du côté du
comptoir vous voulez bien faire escale
on l'a compris les biscuits qui font des
miettes ça c'est votre truc mais on vous
a proposé deux trois petites choses
gourmandes également et puis comme on
fonctionne nous aussi au paillettes
tiens regardez changement de décor la
baie vitrée hop se transforme on vous
emmène et on vous installe du côté de
Guéthary le Sud-Ouest ma deuxième maison
c'est magnifique vous connaissez vous
êtes déjà allé il faut y aller ah bah
oui incroyable guitariste vous savez que
ça Guéthary qui est venu m'a demandé en
mariage il paraît il paraît
aussi que vous avez été ami avant d'être
amoureux vous vous souvenez de la
bascule je me souviens de la bascule on
s'est dit avec Kevin on s'est dit je
t'aime avant d'être en couple ah oui oui
en été meilleurs amis à l'époque j'avais
un amoureux quand j'ai
Kevin et il a été très intelligent il me
le dit encore aujourd'hui qu'il était
comme ça dans son coin et qu'il
attendait il attendait son moment il
savait que ça allait arriver à un moment
ou un autre mais vous aussi vous sentiez
que c'était la bonne personne je sentais
je sentis j'ai senti très vite et en
fait c'est très bizarre de ressentir ça
en fait c'est hyper bizarre de se dire
punaise c'est l'homme de ma vie mais
genre sur rien sur une ouverture de
porte un regard oh mon dieu je veux je
veux vivre toute ma vie avec lui je veux
je veux avoir des enfants je vais avoir
un kangoo je veux qu'on fasse du
jardinage c'est trop bizarre alors que
tu vois le gars vite fait et tu penses
déjà comme ça mais donc trois ans ce
sont écoulés néanmoins entre à la fois
cette évidence cette amitié qui se
transforme et puis votre main qu'il
demande vous êtes manucuré comme
aujourd'hui je crois à ce moment-là
j'avoue c'est horrible parce qu'en fait
je me doutais qu'il allait faire la
demande et ce jour là j'ai du vernis
cahier
et ça peut pas se passer comme ça on est
d'accord donc du coup bah allez go go
manucure manucure avant d'aller au resto
et il me fait la demande devant la plage
et ça c'est un magnifique moment en plus
il est tout petit je crois j'ai jamais
raconté ça mais il est tout timide et
j'ai jamais raconté ma demande je pense
il avait de rien et il avait acheté une
c'est comme une petite pochette
à bijoux ou enfin voilà on met des
choses et dessus il y avait écrit Marry
Me sur la sur la pochette et il arrive
il va me tuer il arrive il fait ça
et moi je suis là
je ne comprends pas et il m'a répondu
Bali
non non ça fait tu me fais un truc à la
n'oublie jamais tu donnes s'il te plaît
et donc du coup après j'ai compris j'ai
eu la bague et aujourd'hui on est marié
et ça fait 8 ans qu'on est ensemble Inès
un fauteuil douillet que vous attend
dans lequel vous allez pouvoir vous
installer est-ce que c'est incroyable
Pigna colada oh là là vous vous avez du
nez
elle est rien que pour vous mais c'est
toute ma vie ça pourrait être exact
c'est la Virgin Piña Colada encore plus
précis non ah bah c'est encore fait
pressé parce que
moi je suis une enfant je comprends pas
les adultes qui mettent de l'alcool
dedans ça dénature le sucre les gars
accessoirement pour le téléspectateur
c'est évidemment votre lune de miel avec
Kevin ou vous avez quand même fait de
l'aquagym je tiens à le dire et je vous
laisse faire quelques pas jusqu'au
fauteuil non mais attendez vous avez pas
fait ça quand même
alors vous êtes bien calé ouais je suis
bien
un petit détour par la droite elle est
sur la tablette voilà et vous pouvez
appuyer sur n'importe quel bouton
je galère avec les mecs mais quand je
dise galère c'est pas genre
ne me regarde pas avec compassion quand
je dis ça mais c'est pas je galère genre
je galère mignon non moi je galère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidence Inès je sais que à la maison
vous étiez le rayon de soleil vous savez
faire rire oncle tente toute la famille
etc mais à l'école à l'école au collège
est-ce que ça a été plus compliqué
à la fois en termes de scolarité elle a
et en terme d'environnement du coup
au collège non 4e c'est là où j'ai
commencé à je suis obliger mes camarades
à m'appeler Inès la star je m'en veux si
vous estimer si on les gâche désolé
mais du coup là à partir de la quatrième
je sais là où vraiment
je ma réparti elle commence là déjà mais
c'est vrai qu'avant c'est un peu plus
compliqué je suis très petite je fais un
mètre 50 aujourd'hui je vous laisse
imaginer ma taille quand j'étais
beaucoup plus jeune et du coup c'est un
peu plus compliqué j'ai cette esprit là
je suis drôle j'ai envie de rire avec
mes camarades mais j'ai pas j'ai pas
d'amis clairement j'ai pas d'amis les
gens ne m'aiment pas beaucoup parce que
je suis petite
je ne saurais pas expliquer dans quoi
j'ai une primaire compliquée douloureuse
mais en vrai aujourd'hui c'est enfin
aujourd'hui je pense
à tous les jeunes qui vont souffrir de
ça et je leur envoie ma force et il faut
qu'ils en parlent il faut que mais
aujourd'hui genre je suis guéri
j'essaie de vous dire que ça va très
bien ça ne m'a pas ça a pas changé ma
vie ça m'a pas donné ça m'a permis de
carence aujourd'hui vraiment pas mais
ouais c'est compliqué c'est c'est dur et
même quand c'est le début d'avoir des
premiers amoureux et qu'on me dit ouais
mais non toi c'est mort tu es trop
petite c'est dommage moi j'ai entendu
cette phrase à l'époque du collège où on
essaye de se faire coquette pour sortir
avec le beau gosse de la cour et qu'on
dit ouais c'est dommage hein tu es jolie
mais tu es naine c'est mort
waouh
et je rentrais
alors vous avez grandi vous avez trouvé
votre place et vous êtes
réinventé très vite très tôt avec avec
une envie de toucher à tout regardons
c'est vous qui avez appuyé sur le bouton
salut
[Musique]
il m'a envoyé un message là on va dans
les falaises en face ou pas
des efforts physiques prolongés
[Musique]
votre premier film la comédie romantique
je te veux moi non plus avec Kevin on
l'a reconnu Rodolphe
vous êtes pressé Inès
je suis pressée non je suis pas pressée
en fait
je j'ouvre les en fait j'ai pas pressé
mais je suis accueillante
en fait je me dis tout simplement si ça
arrive si on me fait la proposition
c'est que c'est maintenant c'est que
c'est le moment et c'est que je suis
prête et on se rend pas à ce moment-là
on y met notre cœur on y met notre
sincérité et ce film a été un carton sur
elle donc c'est faux Inès il y a quand
même effectivement l'aspect chanteuse
aussi le micro vous l'avez pris vous
avez testé votre voix déjà sur scène à
l'époque du Marrakech du rire et même
avant mais il y a cette appétence
puisque gamine vous en aviez envie
poussez la chansonnette franchement je
voulais être chanteuse
peut-être indice
franchement je m'en veux un dans sa
méchante amoureuse de la scène à la
folie et des fois j'avoue alors voilà ça
par contre c'est un projet à chaque fois
on me dit ouais vas-y fais lance-toi
sors un son encore fait un album etc je
suis je suis horrible je suis tellement
amoureuse de cette arnaque du stand-up
que en vrai je ne veux vivre rien
d'autre que ça donc non en fait je crie
au monde je suis une nana du stand-up je
suis je suis une meuf de la scène et je
veux jamais vous quitter je veux rester
là il y a que là que ah si vous saviez
comme je suis heureuse Inès est-ce que
vous voulez bien faire quelque part oui
vers le miroir qui se trouve à l'opposé
l'appartement
en face de vous je vous dis que vous y
fassiez escale comme ça 30 secondes si
vous êtes d'accord parce que parce que
je me souviens à vous avoir entendu dire
que Inès votre prénom c'était Inès pour
Inès de la Fressange votre maman qui
avait ce c'est vous qui t'avait dit
qu'il avait espoir que vous lui
ressembliez aujourd'hui du haut de vos
30 ans comment vous vous regardez
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de plus mignon chez
vous
par reproche c'est pas le mot mais c'est
vrai que tout le monde me dit j'ai cette
dentition un peu particulière mais je
trouve qu'elle fait celle que je suis
aujourd'hui et j'aime ma bouche parce
que ma maman m'a toujours dit que
j'avais qu'elle aimait énormément qui
est trop bien les dents elles sont pas
alignées ça va un peu de tous les côtés
c'est ce qui fait ton chat mais c'est ce
qui fait la nanaké aujourd'hui et elle
m'a appris du coup à aimer ce qui est
sûrement mon défaut est-ce que vous
voulez bien faire deux pas un petit
tabouret quelques quelques disques des
33 tours même derrière vous voilà
des 33 tours notre propre sélection mais
qui se rapporte à vos goûts vous pouvez
vous asseoir et nous proposer un disque
à l'écoute si notre sélection vous
inspire mais elle m'inspire énormément
au point que je ne sais pas que choisir
Orelsan aussi je suis obligée d'écouter
Orelsan alors
on va écouter alors
c'est tellement dingue alors par contre
assez en plus j'en ai un à la maison
c'est celui de Kevin j'ai pas le droit
d'y toucher
je fais n'importe quoi
ensuite vous prenez le manche et vous
allez poser délicatement le diamant sur
le sillon un peu au hasard je pense
bah ouais
ce mec est incroyable
en plus
et très très bonne faire comprendre des
choses et au-delà de ça
le gage c'est une semaine à Versoix et
ça c'est classe et j'avoue que j'ai un
peu ma petite fierté parce que j'ai fait
une semaine à l'Olympia et dans une de
ses musiques il dit Paris merci merci je
pose
je pose une semaine à Bercy et du coup
bah j'avoue l'avoir mettre inspiré avoir
dit à Paris merci merci j'ai posé ma
semaine à l'Olympia et je vais terminer
à l'accord Arena
alors en attendant on a un petit cadeau
quand même pour vous regarder dans
l'angle là vous êtes bien placé une
boîte que vous pouvez ouvrir
j'aime trop les cadeaux
le cumul le cumul expert de jeux de
société dessin animé Totally Spies
j'adore et voilà les gars merci de ton
cœur grand jeu d'enquête interactif des
Spice je savais même mais non attendez
je peux vraiment prendre juste le le
poudrier oui vous pouvez je vais prendre
l'ensemble hein
il faut que je finisse avec le ah ouais
waouh merci de tout mon cœur
évidemment spécial Inès est-ce que vous
voulez bien nous laisser un petit cliché
de vous on aimerait bien vous avoir dans
le dans l'espace en aparté dans
l'appartement l'appareil photo vers le
comptoir deuxième étagère de la
bibliothèque
ok alors attendez je veux faire la photo
avec avec
le prendre en main et il y a une petite
pastille orange
autre chose il y a une photo d'evangelis
orange qui efface voilà sur la d'abord
pour allumer donc une première fois donc
là j'ai allumé ensuite bien vous
positionnez comme vous le voulez et
c'est sur la patience aussi que j'appuie
pour ok je peux me positionner où je
veux exactement trop bien je vais aller
devant la fiche de Bercy
comme ça ça va me donner de la force
avec le copy
je sais pas si je vais réussir à bien
viser tout ça mais ok
génial
tout à l'heure pour que vous l'ayez en
souvenir
merci beaucoup Inès c'était
effectivement un soleil comme l'a
toujours dit votre famille un soleil
dans cet appartement là aussi
kevini Kevin il est venu ou pas non
Kevin n'est pas là aujourd'hui
mais il va recevoir son appel
téléphonique avec tout le débrief
n'oubliez pas la boîte entière des
Totally Spies le jeu de société avec la
déclinaison du dessin animé oui à tout
mais c'est trop dingue j'ai hâte d'y
jouer vraiment merci merci pour ce
moment j'ai passé un très très bon
moment délicieux de vous recevoir
en haut des marches les escaliers de
tout à l'heure je pose ça
là j'ai tout foiré
une catastrophe
c'est pas grave je rembarque ça aussi
parce qu'il faut tout laisser propre
on passera derrière la maison
ah génial on se refait pas bravo Inès ça
te va te signature une d'entre elles en
tout cas merci c'était un plaisir hors
norme vous avez foulé déjà mille scène
et le rendez-vous c'est l'accord Arena
le 17 juin on sera en rendez-vous après
le Casino de Paris après les enidis
d'après le Lympia hors norme oui votre
terrain de jeu le 17 juin d'accord Arena
à Paris on viendra vous saluer vous
applaudir merci vous embrasse
à bientôt à bientôt
plus personne écoute tout le monde
s'exprime personne change d'avis que des
débats tout le monde sait que c'est
parce que tout le monde sait que c'est
que des opinions tranchées rien n'est
jamais précis plus le temps de réfléchir
tyrannie des chiffres gamins de 12 ans
dans les médiacités l'intelligence fait
moins vendre que la polémique Battle
Royale se chacun pour sa petite équipe
connard enfin je connais
quelque chose de mal quelque part le
monde entier devient susceptible